là ça fait trop du bien des combats
quitter la ville là c'est le silence là
les deux derniers jours on les a passés
bah en ville avec le bruit des voitures
le bruit des moteurs et là juste avoir
du silence moi je trouve ça incroyable
[Musique]
des centaines de personnes dont beaucoup
de très jeunes à visage découvert
ce sont retrouvés vers 22h avec pour
certains l'objectif de maintenir la
pression sur le gouvernement
que des préjugés des clichés après
quelques échauffourés et plusieurs
interpellations le calme a été rétabli
vers deux heures du matin
des vitrines qui se rétractent en moins
d'une seconde à la moindre agression
toute relié par le même système une
invention à 15000 euros pièce réservée
aux bijoux les plus chers
autre dispositif c'est plots intelligent
avec laser quand un bijou disparaît il
commande automatiquement le blindage de
la vitrine
[Musique]
le Time explique assez lecteurs que la
violence de rue fait partie de la vie
politique en France depuis la Révolution
d'ailleurs c'est presque devenu un
cliché pour les Anglais le Daily Express
s'abuse d'un homme vu en train de manger
tranquillement un sandwich au milieu des
affrontements comme si de rien n'était
c'est la chose la plus anglaise que vous
puissiez voir écrit le journal sur les
vidéos les mêmes visages juvéniles
selon nos informations en région
parisienne certains émeutiers n'ont que
13 ans je fais des burgers maison 100%
maison viande du boucher pain du
boulanger un truc un peu qualitatif
j'imagine qu'ils doivent être bon je
vois qu'ils sont bons
alors sorti de garde à vue certains
ressortent 100 poursuites et sans gêne
devant leurs parents
entre ce maître nageur expérimenté et
ses garçons pleins d'énergie une
relation amicale s'est instaurée tu
faisais quoi
aujourd'hui
et oui et oui Nanterre hier le mémorial
de la déportation a été tagué un homme
briquet à la main se penche pour mettre
le feu un drapeau quand une femme a
droite de l'image l'interrompt en tirant
sur les tofs elle s'approche de lui pose
la main sur son épaule et tente de le
raisonner et départ une seconde personne
tirer aime son métier car grâce à lui il
est constamment au contact des jeunes
comme la question a été avant c'est
bonjour
comment ne pas les apprécier en plus
quand ils sont gentils et intelligemment
je veux que ça s'arrête partout cette
jeunesse gage sa vie pour rien notre
phrase du jour est signée Nadia la
grand-mère de Naël a pris la parole
aujourd'hui cinq jours après la mort de
son petit-fils tué par un tir de police
alors que de nombreux émeutiers
justifient leurs actes en évoquant ce
drame elle lance ce soir un appel au
calme les policiers heureusement qu'ils
sont là je la cite les gens qui sont en
train de casser je leur dis arrêtez ou
un autre véhicule avec des mots scotché
sous le pare-brise le propriétaire
implorant de ne pas la détruire je ne
suis pas assuré tout risque justice pour
Naël et puis les tabloïdes portent un
regard sévère sur le président français
Macron danse pendant que la France brûle
à titré le Daily Mail faisant référence
à la présence du président de la
République au concert d'Elton John
mercredi soir et c'est bien là le souci
car cette personne malveillante n'est
pas un délinquant on doit composer avec
et les conséquences sont néfastes pour
notre santé et notre bien-être par son
comportement sans gêne il fait naître
stress burn out anxiété perte de
confiance harcèlement bref c'est un
parasite pour la société une société
2023 qui les fabrique à la chaîne et en
bref ce communiqué de deux puissances
Syndicates de police qui fait beaucoup
réagir leur n'est pas à l'action
syndicale mais au combat contre ces
nuisibles déclarent je cite alliance et
une sapolis et de poursuivre aujourd'hui
les policiers sont au combat car nous
sommes en guerre mais son plus grand
fait d'arme en matière de connardise
reste celui-ci qu'il raconte tout Guy
face caméra
l'avocat du policier est mis en examen
s'exprimer sur les plateaux les premiers
mots qu'il a prononcé c'était pour dire
pardon ce qu'il a fait était nécessaire
au moment où il l'a fait il a estimé que
c'était nécessaire
déjà je voudrais vous remercie pour vous
remercier pardon pour l'invitation parce
que c'est très difficile de paraître
dans les médias pour commenter
l'actualité tout au long de l'année
parce que les banlieues c'est aussi la
France mais on a aussi une vie et
quelque part on aimerait aussi
participer à l'actualité de notre France
régulièrement pour déjà faire taire ceux
qui nous rendent invisible ou ceux qui
pensent que on est désintéressé où on
n'aime pas la France c'est déjà mal
connaître les banlieues parce que les
banlieues ça reste la France cet
après-midi devant la carcasse encore
fumante de cette
maison est totalement désemparée
pourquoi ils ont fait ça je comprends
pas je n'arrive pas à comprendre là
c'est trop c'est trop petit
reproduisant en plateau une destruction
de chambre d'hôtel avec le concours de
l'animateur amusé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
français
et au fond le diagnostic d'un connard
c'est quelqu'un qui savoure les
avantages du pouvoir mais qui ne veut à
aucun moment s'encombrer des obligations
respecter les autres les écouter
accueillir leurs critique leur remarques
éventuellement je suis un enfant des
cités HLM
élevé dans la mixité
les valeurs de partage et de respect de
l'autre quel que soit son origine
sa couleur
sa religion je ne peux accepter
que mon nom et ma famille soit sali de
la sorte
j'ai donc décidé d'attaquer en justice
quiconque pour atteinte à mon honneur